[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the podcast the show where I
go deep and long-form with some of the
most interesting and compelling thought
leaders across all categories of health
wellness diet nutrition entrepreneurship
spirituality got a great episode for you
guys today my friend Paul Shapiro joins
the podcast Paul is the vice president
of policy engagement for the Humane
Society of the US he's also the founder
of compassion over killing and a member
of the animal rights Hall of Fame Paul
is also the author of a brand-new book
his first book it's an amazing read it's
called clean meat it's a Washington Post
bestseller and it is a look behind the
scenes at this crazy wild ride to create
and ultimately commercialize sustainable
real meat without the animals so-called
left groan meat which is essentially
animal cells that are grown or brewed to
create not only food products but
commercial products as well it's an
amazing story this is a fantastic
conversation like I said Paul and I go
way back we're good friends and I think
you guys are gonna really enjoy this
discourse on the future of food so
without further ado please enjoy my
conversation with Paul Shapiro peace
plants cuz I know you're like you're
kind of a an astronomy Star Trek nerd
also like that's a part and there was
also that that kind of kerfuffle that
that occurred when Neil deGrasse Tyson
tweeted something about cows and Moby
reacted and it became a whole
controversy that you then wrote a
Huffington Post article about so tell me
about that I'm a big fan of Neil's I
follow him I read his books listen to
his podcast and in 2015 I noticed he
kept talking about animals not in the
sense of animals like that they ought to
be protected you just kept on having the
about animals like he would say oh I
sometimes wonder when the cows look at
the moon what they think oh my god
that's interesting his thing about cows
so I emailed him and I was like dude you
totally I'll do a show about animals I'd
love to come on and talk with you about
it and to my great pleasure he I'm only
back and said when are you gonna be in
New York next haha I was like four hours
from now
good for you man so I went up there yeah
this is back in 2015 and I did an
episode with him and it went very well
and then they asked me they're like hey
if we're gonna be in New York again a
second day cuz we would like to do
another taping with you I said yeah of
course I'll be in New York another day
which I'm calling the boss up I'm like
yo I gotta change my ticket so I did too
only one of them ended up airing but it
was still fun to do and so when I
maintain communication with him and when
the whole thing blew up with Moby where
Moby had called him a sociopath for this
tweet that he issued right well explain
the tweet yeah maybe or maybe was
responding to Neil's tweet in which he
said that a cow is a biological machine
invented by humans to convert grass into
meat and you know in Neil's mind
biological machine doesn't mean in
sentient it doesn't mean they don't feel
pain he views us as biological machines
too it's more about our relationship as
humans to that animal yeah I think that
you're right maybe you know I took it in
a different way
yeah and I talked with movie about and
he to his great credit apologized and
thought he went overboard in his
criticism and I wrote a piece for
Huffington Post about it in which I said
you know look humans invented cows in
the ways that we invented dogs they
didn't exist in nature and we
domesticated animals in this case the
ORAC which is the animal now extinct
because we exterminated them but that's
the animal from whom we descended the
same animal yeah and we amended them in
that sense that we domesticated them and
created a new species of animal like
dogs are two wolves but we didn't cause
them to turn grass into meat that's what
all ruminants do giraffes cows deer you
know that's just the nature of what they
do and so I thought that I thought that
was a little bit off the wall to suggest
that Neil's response to that was
well we got them to do it more
efficiently I was like well that may be
true but that doesn't mean we invented
them to do that
so anyway it was an interesting argument
and Neil himself only eats meat he says
about two times per week so in 1991
meals according to him or vegetarian
which was pretty good for everybody do
that I might go find something else to
do with my life so when you were with
him most recently to do the show again
did you guys hash this out or what was
the subject of that conversation yeah so
he was interviewing me about the book
clean meat but he also wanted to talk
about that too so he went into it and
you know I I defend Neil in the sense
that I don't think his intent was to
suggest that cows are just machines
that's clearly not what is in his head
in fact he has done videos for animal
protection groups in the past talking
about the intelligence of animals and
how often we underestimate the mental
lives of other animals in the same way
that you know we used to think that the
earth was flat or that the earth was the
center of the universe we're now
starting to realize that well even if
the earth is in the center of the
physical universe we still really
believe that humanity is the center of
the moral universe and that notion is
being challenged by people including
Neil mm-hmm interesting that's cool well
we are here to talk about clean meat
it's funny like when we were going back
and forth to like schedule the podcast I
was like well send me the book you know
and you're like well digital or print
and I was like print ads is better
because it'll sit on my desk I'll see it
when my tiny delete read it and you know
what comes in the mail like you
literally printed it out your printer I
thought you're gonna send me like a
galley and then oh man then I felt bad I
didn't mind it at all but I just didn't
have any gas at the time and I would
love to get you what you need man right
well it's cool yeah I got here right
away the book is amazing we're gonna dig
into it but before we do that perhaps we
can kind of contextualize this a little
bit by speaking to your background so
why don't you talk a little bit about
HSUS how you got there
what you do for them and kind of what
led you to get interested in this clean
meat movement and write this book
sure well I'm going to put it in a small
nutshell to avoid boring you with the
whole biography which I know that you
are
already familiar with since we go back
but first see we were to the same well
you went to you you mainly went to
Georgetown day right but you were at
Landon for a minute I was there for
grades three through six so when Landon
is where rich went to school as well and
I had a little bit of like a trigger
moments when I was reading finding Ultra
because when you were writing about the
painted white rocks that you know you're
driving up that driveway to the school
he says painted white rocks and you and
I had similar experiences there meaning
not the best and to read about Landon
and the tough time that you had there
and then just something about those
rocks that's reading I was like oh yeah
I don't want to go back there I've never
heard of it of those rocks being
described as triggers but that's kind of
what it said yeah it's definitely a semi
traumatic experience for me you know you
got out before high school I knew I knew
by sixth grade it wasn't for me it was
just very counter to my personality and
you know there's some people who really
are into it but I was not one yeah so
wait so if you were there from third to
six we might have been there at the same
time
you graduated 85 no no sadly we would
like to believe anyway so all right so
the here's the thing that's cool though
I just had nathan Runkle on the show and
he was talking about how you know he got
interested in in animal rights very
young and started Mercy for Animals when
he was like 15 or something like that
and you have a very similar story yeah
Nathan and I kind of led parallel lives
in that sense and so when I was 13 years
old a friend of mine showed me this
video of what happens to animals and
factory farms and in slaughter plants
and he wasn't showing it to me like as a
form of outreach I mean you remember
phases of death remember that video yeah
passed around yeah it was like the cool
thing to watch right that's people
animals dying right and it wasn't like
this was horrific this was like some
cool thing that boys watched and that's
what my friend showed he's like dude you
got to watch this it's sick
and I watched it and I didn't planned it
like sick I find a sickening and I was
like holy [ __ ] like what if these were
my dogs in this video well there were my
dogs in that slaughter plant what if
there were my dogs and in those cages
and so I became a vegetarian and then
you know pretty quickly thereafter I
started reading like I sent letters this
is back in 1993 so I've used no internet
or anything I just wrote snail mail
letters to these groups and asked them
to send me information on vegetarianism
so I got back these like things from
animal groups and I started reading
about it
yeah pamphlets booklets and I'm like
what are vegans you know like what is a
vegan and I thought to myself oh you
know actually I'm reading what's
happening to egg and dairy industries is
really bad I'm like but I don't I think
that you you die like I thought like
being one of these so-called vague ins
you would like be like holding your
breath like you can hold your breath for
a certain amount of time but if you do
it too long you die and I thought if you
can go maybe like a week or two but you
can't go oh girl wife without EAM so I
started volunteering for these groups as
a kid and I met these people who I
warned were called vegans and I started
talking them that I'm like looking at
them want to see if they will pay on a
see if they look like they're about to
waste away I'm like I couldn't believe
it was like these apparitions in front
of me and then one of them told me that
Carl Lewis was vegan and you know back
then Carl Lewis was like you know the
Michael Phelps so that Usain Bolt of
today like the premier Olympian athlete
who everybody knew and I was like are
you kidding me and so I looked up this
they gave me like an interview of with
Carlos it and how we attributed vegan
eating to his success I mean it's
obviously many other factors but he said
that was part of it and I was like well
if Carl Lewis is a vegan ah movie again
so I became vegan and then when I got to
high school there was no animal
protection Club so I started one called
compassion over killing I quickly
realized I didn't want it to be a high
school club anymore and so I converted
it into at first to Washington DC wide
organization and then toward the end of
my high school career into a national
organization yeah that to this day is
now it's a huge organization they're
doing great things yeah my are you still
involved like how do you what's your
relationship with the or
you started huh I root Amman I cheer for
their success I am not involved they're
doing wonderful things and I basically
you know when I came to the Humane
Society of the United States after ten
years of running compassion over killing
the workload involved in being at HSUS
was such that it wasn't possible for me
to do both and so they're doing great
things they now have offices in DC and
in LA and they just put out a new
undercover investigation of a chicken a
chicken factory farm that has led to
really good outcomes and high amounts of
media attention so how about what
they're doing right cool so you find
your way to HSUS and you've been there
for a long time now 13 years yeah I came
on when wayne Pacelle we became
president so you know back then you know
HSUS was not known as a advocacy
organization for the most part of our
people just thought it was like dogs and
cats and certainly I did advocacy for
them but mostly they weren't known for
that but when Wayne became president
first he was the first vegan president
of the organization and second he was
this young guy he was 39 at the time who
had a history of animal advocacy of
running political campaigns and other
types of efforts for animals and many of
us thought to ourselves you know I can't
believe this guy he's president of the
largest animal protection group on earth
and Wayne had an interest in starting a
farm animal protection campaign which
the organization hadn't had at that
point and asked those of us at
compassion over killing if we would come
on over to the new organization this new
hsus under him and try to do that in 13
years later still happening still there
so how do you distinguish the work of
HSUS versus the other animal rights
organizations the PETA is the Mercy for
Animals katashi overkilling like what is
what's different or what is the mission
statement that distinguishes the work
that you guys do sure so one aspect that
is different is that HSUS is focused on
all animals whereas groups like
compassion over killing or Mercy for
Animals are focused solely on farm
animals at the same time what really
distinguishes HSUS is not just that it's
a rescue indirect care organization it's
got
wildlife rehab centers and animal
sanctuaries and so on but that it is
also the premier organization when it
comes to public policy for animals we
want to create the type of organization
like what the NRA is for gun owners for
animals we want politicians to know that
they'll be rewarded if they vote for
animals and that they'll be punished if
they vote against animals so hsus has a
large presence in the congress and in
nearly all 50 state legislatures and in
a lot of city and county councils as
well working hard to both pass
legislation to move the ball forward for
animals including farm animals and to
fight back bad legislation that's
harmful to animals too right and so what
is your role role so I serve as the vice
president of policy engagement and I
work with at the federal and state level
to pass new laws to help protect animals
especially farm animals we're working on
a ballot measure here in California
right now that would create the
strongest farm animal protection law
both in the country and in the world
that would require that any of the veal
eggs or pork that are sold in California
regardless of where they were produced
have to come from animals who are not
confined in cages and are given space
allotments that are higher legal
requirements than anywhere else on the
planet and that would be kind of that
would be leading legislation sort of
nationwide right
without a doubt yeah and what about what
are the prospects for that passing well
we have a lot of opposition from the
veal industry from the egg industry from
the pork industry and that time will
come to fight them but right now we have
to get on the ballot which means that we
have to gather over half a million
signatures so that requires a lot of
volunteers so for people who live in
California they can go to prevent
cruelty see a calm and sign up to
volunteer because if we don't get on the
ballot there's no chance of having that
fight against the factory farming
industry but if we do get on the ballot
California will become the central front
in the national debate over factory
farming in all eyes within the
agribusiness industry and in the Animal
Protection community are going to be
focused here on the Golden State so like
the front line of where this battle is
being waged without a doubt but we have
to get on the ballot first right so
let's let's take a step back and kind of
canvass the current sort of situate
legislative regulatory situation with
spec to factory farming you know with
poultry beef and pork like where do we
stand right now where where where are
the other battles that need to be waged
like what are we up against and kind of
what's going on yeah well let me just
tell you a brief story then so imagine
that you're out late at dinner and under
the darkness of night a burglar comes
into your home and breaks in grabs a
painting of a pig off of your wall and
smashes that painting the charge for
that act of vandalism will be criminal
property destruction but now imagine
that at a pork factory that a farmer
notices a piglet who isn't growing as
fast as their siblings and picks her up
and smashes her head against the
concrete floor killing her and throwing
her body away the charge for that act of
violence is nothing because it's
standard operating practice in the
Parkers in the pork industry and what
I'm saying is that farm animals have so
little legal protection that you can get
in greater legal trouble for smashing a
painting of a pig than an actual living
feeling pig that's how bad it is well
you can get in even more trouble if
you're somebody who's trying to pull
covers and yes in nations we be
considered a domestic terrorist right
right yeah you might get in more trouble
for taking a photo or a video of
somebody smashing a pig hood against the
concrete floor than the person
committing the actual act of violence so
farm animals are in a dire position they
have so little legal protection that
passing laws that require them to have
for example cage free living conditions
they certainly are modest but they're
enormous Lee historic because they get
these animals protections that they
don't have and the agribusiness industry
has been so good at exempting themselves
from state anti-cruelty laws and from
from preventing any federal legislation
that really these guys can do pretty
much anything they want to farm animals
and get away with it
for the most part why are they so good
is it just money and lobbying groups
well there's a couple factors yes money
and they're lobbying groups but - it's
because the animal movement isn't
politically organized especially not for
farm animals I mean the fact is that
laws are created by people who show up
most animal advocates are not
politically engaged and
is why the agribusiness Lobby has been
able to do all this think about it
less than 1% of the American population
is involved in farming any of any kind
not just animal AG of any farming then
thing about just a few percentages of us
are vegetarians or vegans and then a
huge majority of people consider
themselves animal lovers so the number
of people who want to protect animals is
much greater than the number of people
who want to abuse animals but the animal
movement has not been politically
organized in the way that the
agribusiness Lobby or the gun lobby for
example has been well as much as it is
about organization it's about political
well as well because amongst those
animal lovers are just the average you
know relatively compassionate consumer
they're just not engaged because they
don't know what's going on and they're
busy with their lives right like it's
just it's just sort of the the the the
the big food companies the farming
industry has done an amazing job of
insulating the public from the reality
of the production mechanism that puts
that food into the grocery store yeah I
think you're hitting the nail on the
head most people are blissfully
unfamiliar with how their food is
produced but I also think that it's got
to be a matter of greater priority so
look at the gun issue for example huge
majorities of people think that we ought
to have like basic background checks and
things like that on guns but they don't
make it their number-one priority issue
for voting and so politicians know
they're probably not going to be
penalized if they've against these
people's wishes the same is so for
animal issues if you put on the ballot
and give people a chance to vote on it
independently overwhelmingly they tend
to vote for it in the same way they
would for the background checks on guns
but if a politician votes against
animals how many voters are going to
punish them for that vote that's what we
need to make sure happens and it has
happened in some cases but there needs
to be more examples yeah that's
interesting
and where do we currently stand with
respect to the ag-gag laws well the
there are probably been about three
dozen ag-gag bills that have been
introduced and virtually all of them
have been thwarted in the legislature by
HSUS fighting them and making
they don't become a gag laws a few have
gotten through and groups like the
Animal Legal Defense Fund have had a lot
of success fighting them in the courts
and nullifying them in states like Utah
and in in Idaho as well
Iowa's still is in effect and it's
really important because I was the
biggest egg and production state in the
country and there has been a recent
challenge to it that's now pending so
ag-gag laws are a problem but they're in
very few states there's a lot of
attention on them because they are so
suggestive they show like this is not an
industry that wants to prevent abuse
they want to prevent people from finding
out about abuse but it is into the case
that most states have them it's a tiny
minority of them that do right that's
interesting I mean I would imagine the
constitutional challenge to this is
pretty strong yeah the problem is AG gag
laws come in various flavors they all
have the same outcome which is to
prevent undercover investigations but
they are different so you have some that
are straight-up bans on photography they
have others that make it a crime to lie
on a job application if you are applying
an agricultural operation they so you
could ask on the application like are
you affiliated with an animal welfare
group and normally if you lie on a job
application that's cause for being fired
if they find out they want to make it a
crime to do that and I mean if
embellishing your resume is a crime you
know there's gonna be you very invest in
prisons
I would never got my job without the
tourism lobbies yeah exactly so but
they're so shady about it that it's only
at agricultural operations if you want
to lie on your resume to apply to be a
banker or investor go right ahead but if
you do it to become a farm laborer then
you can go to jail it's really insidious
and who are the people on the hill in
Congress in the Senate who are kind of
championing this cause like who are the
Friends of HSUS that are trying to evoke
change there's really no better champion
that animals have in the Congress than
somebody like Cory Booker democratic
senator from New Jersey get him on the
podcast so he would come on yeah I know
I'm I'm going back and forth with this
okay what's gonna happen okay cool well
I would love to listen to that but yeah
I mean you know senator Booker is a
champion for animals he's a true
believer he's a vegan himself
and he's the real deal but it goes
across the aisle also I mean look in
Arizona for example there's a Republican
lawmaker a congresswoman named Martha
McSally who is vegan herself and is the
sponsor of legislation to ban the sale
of cosmetics that were tested on animals
in the United States so it's not
necessarily a partisan issue but there
are some people who are just real
champions on animal issues like well I
would imagine it's partisan well it's
it's really Geographic that often tends
to be the case that urban as suburban
lawmakers are often friendlier to
animals but not always but it is often
yeah all right so right now it's 2017
were mired in this institution of
factory farming that is slaughtering a
billion animals a year what is the
number it's so staggeringly high like I
never know what it is sadly much more
than that yeah in the u.s. it's about
nine billion land animals a year billion
land animals 1 billion nine billion -
the mind doesn't we didn't evolve to
understand this type of astronomical
figures and it's a system that has
created tremendous economies of scale
but the flip side to that is all of the
environmental havoc that is wreaked as a
result of this everything from ocean
acidification to water table pollution
ocean dead zones species extinction
rainforests decimation I mean it just
goes on and on and on right like it's
right you can't even quantify the amount
of environmental wreckage as a result of
this system that we've created to be as
efficient as possible meanwhile
slaughtering all of these animals many
of which are tortured in the most
inhumane way you can possibly
conceptualize sure meanwhile we're
continuing to propagate the planet with
humans and we're quickly escalating
towards 10 billion people by what like
2050 or something like that right and
that leaves us with this huge question
like how are we going to feed all these
people how are we going to do it in a
way that will ensure that this planet
and its precious resources are still
around to be able to even
provide in the first place yeah which
brings us to what we're here to talk
about today decide this this whole new
emerging world of clean meat yeah so
yeah I think you're hitting the nail on
the head man the problem is that we're
gonna have about 10 billion of us by
2050 most likely and many of those
people want to eat like Americans do
that is a diet that's very heavy and
meat eggs and dairy while those products
are actually inhumane but they're also
among the most resource intensive
products to bring forth into the world
so how do we feed all these people how
do we feed ourselves meat consumption
globally is projected to continue rising
not fall Chinese meat consumption is
quintupled over the last few decades and
it's continuing to rise right the rise
of the middle class there that's right
that's right as people come out of the
developing world and into the developed
world one of the very first things they
do is start eating more animal products
and diets high in animal products are
the diet of the wealthier nations so
this is the diet of affluence and as
soon as countries are no longer mired in
poverty they want to eat more animal
products and so countries like Brazil
Mexico China India their rates of meat
consumption are going up not down in the
United States right now meat consumption
is going up and even though we have the
highest per capita rate of meat
consumption pretty much in world history
so the trends aren't looking good there
are great things that are happening with
the proliferation of plant-based foods
in the marketplace plant-based milk is a
great standout example of a product that
has gained a lot of market share and the
dairy industry has contracted because of
it but when it comes to meat which is
what most animals are raised for you
know things aren't looking good right
now and there needs to be some solution
to this and I'm very bullish on
plant-based meats I think companies like
beyond meat and Guardian and tofurkey I
love them they're great companies I eat
their products myself but just in the
way that fossil fuels are so bad they
present so many problems that we want
multiple alternatives to them wind solar
geothermal and so on we need multiple
alternatives to factory farms and clean
meat is one such alternative that
looks very promising and so I wrote this
book clean me because I wanted to
chronicle the pioneers who are devoting
their lives to making this into a
commercial reality these people many of
whom came out of the animal welfare and
environmental communities to try a new
tactic and see if we can produce real
meat from animal cells rather than
animal slaughter and have people switch
from factory farmed meat to a much
cleaner more humane more sustainable
type of meat yeah I think it's uh it's a
very interesting time as we it's it's
it's almost like it's a race right it is
like we're we're we're in this this arms
race like are we going to be able to
prevail as a species before we destroy
ourselves well that's a very open-ended
question and I think that as as amazing
as it is to see the ascendancy of this
vegan plant-based movement go mainstream
I think you're you're you're ignorant to
believe that it will reach a tipping
point significant enough to really
impact this crisis that we're in in a
meaningful way before it's too late
yeah I mean let's just keep it real less
than one percent of meat that is sold in
the United States comes from plant-based
sources like you know impossible burger
is beyond me at Guardian add it all up
less than 1% of all meat even if it was
at 10% and plant-based milks are now 10%
of the fluid milk market in the US even
that means 90% of all the milk that is
sold is coming from cows virtually all
of whom are factory farmed so if we want
to actually address this problem and
save animals from factory farms and
slaughter plants and start reducing the
amount of greenhouse gas emissions that
agriculture is is producing why wouldn't
we do this this is such a promising
alternative to the current system and
the benefits are manifold obviously to
animals the benefits are great but it's
much cleaner for the planet like clean
energy clean meat is just better for the
planet and it's also literally cleaner
so think about it right now you're
warned to treat wrongly it in your
kitchen almost like toxic waste why
because it's riddled with feces you coli
salmonella Campylobacter these are in
Heston epatha jhin's that can sicken you
if you don't cook the crap out of your
meat literally literally have to cook
the crap out of it right
but with Queen meat you aren't actually
growing intestines which is those are
intestinal pathogens E coli salmonella
Campylobacter you're just growing meat
you take a cell from an animal and make
that cell believe that it is still in
the animal's body by putting in a type
of cultivator that tricks the cell into
thinking that and the cell grows into
muscle tissue just exactly as it would
in the animal's body except outside of
the animal's body with far fewer
resources because rather than creating
an entire animal you only have to grow
the meat you actually want so it is
truly cruelty free humane meat but it's
also much cleaner again for the planet
and for food safety yeah and without the
the the hormones and antibiotics and and
everything else that gets put into this
and and and also you know a lifetime
however short that life may be of eating
GMO grain yeah that's one of the more
interesting things about this because
you know obviously this is the
application of biotechnology to food and
some people get nervous about that in
the same people who are concerned about
GMOs might have that concern but McKay
Jenkins who wrote a very good book
called food fight about the GMO debate
looking at it has a very good point
Jenkins asserts that if you really are
concerned about GMOs and you want to
reduce the amount of GMO crops planted
the number one thing you should be
rooting for is clean meat because 90% of
GMO crops are fed to farm animals now
cleanly it doesn't require genetic
modification you don't need to use GMO
technology to produce clean meat but now
you could but none of the companies are
doing that who are producing the meat
right now they're not using GMO
technology but if they succeed they will
certainly be displacing a huge portion
of farm animals who would otherwise be
eating GMO feed I get that but there
also is there is engineering here we're
embarking into this new terrain that's
very strange and very new because the
world is changing very rapidly yeah and
so there is a there is a logical
rational argument to say hey wait a
minute like all right before we just
dive into
what are the long-term implications on
human health has anybody looked at that
in a meaningful way so I mean that
question needs to be asked and explored
oh I totally agree it must be and the
answer is no of course not I mean many
will argue these are functionally the
same exact thing there's no difference
it is just growing the same exact cells
producing the same exact meat just
outside of their body but you're right I
mean there's not possible for there to
have been long term Studies on this
because the first company devoted to
commercial I think queen meat Memphis
meats was founded in 2016 and you're one
of the few people on the planet maybe a
hundred people or something like that
that I've actually tried this yeah it's
probably a little bit more than that now
but I was one of the first maybe maybe
100 or so to eat it and I starting in
2014 I started eating some clean meats
I've now eating clean beef duck fish
liver chorizo yogurt all lab gren land
add things about that first of all like
after whatever 20 years I had to be
weird
yeah and secondarily if you can recall
like what is the the taste comparison
and the texture comparison and all of
that
sure so again I went vegan in 1993 so
for me is I'm not maybe not the best
judge to say whether it tastes like meat
but to me it tasted a lot like meat
because it is meat you know and you
either beyond burger and you're thinking
oh does this taste like meat well that's
an alternative to meat that tastes very
meat like this isn't an alternative to
meat it is meat and that's why it tastes
like meat because that's exactly what it
is and yeah it was weird for me I mean
there's a long time vegan I felt like I
didn't have any ethical concerns about
it you had no ethical quandary about it
no ethical quandary but it was an
identity quandary because when you
business me yeah - right am I still a
vegetarian even and frankly I have less
concern about the personal identity
issues although I do think a lot of
people will be concerned about them but
clean meat isn't for vegans you know
this is intended to displace factory
farms not plant-based proteins so the
goal isn't to get vegans to eat this
it's to get people who right now we're
buying meat from fast food companies and
supermarkets to switch to this one it's
commercially available
right which is the real issue so what
are there are people though who want to
kick you off the team
I'm sure creatures of wanting to be you
know have this identity and be part of a
group whatever that group may be that's
right all kinds of weirdness around that
yeah I think for some people it's like
they would rather have a social club
than a social movement and that's the
reality and for them there's like
orthodoxy litmus tests that if you do X
you're at it you're excommunicated from
the group I have a feeling for those
people clean meat is a violation of that
test but what is the point of the group
to begin with yes right emulate an
advocate change and and and you know and
hopefully you know create a mainstream
shift in our relationship with these
products that are you know raised in a
horrible way and are creating all these
problems the further planet that's what
you and I want and I think that's what a
lot of vegans want but I think some
vegans really do want to be
countercultural for them if it became
mainstream it would be less attractive
it's like when your band makes it big
yeah he's signed a big label sellout and
that's exactly right so I had I had your
friend and your colleague and my friend
Bruce Friedrich on and it's a proud of
year ago and and we explored clean meat
but it's been a year there's a lot of
new listeners so you know probably would
be a good idea to at least define our
terms and and you know specifically
address what we're talking about when
we're talking about clean meat sure so
right now we have the capacity to take a
tiny biopsy think about like a sesame
seed sized biopsy from an animal and in
that biopsy from muscle tissue there are
what are known as satellite cells and
these are the cells that create muscle
when your muscle is injured either from
a workout or you get bruised
those cells go to work and produce a new
muscle we can isolate those cells and
make them think that they're in the body
and have them produce muscle it's the
same exact skeletal muscle that people
eat when they eat meat it's not a
different type of muscle it is literally
the same muscle
and we can grow that outside of the
animal's body and produce meat that is
the same as regular meat except much
more sanitary much eco-friendly er and
of course much more humane and some
companies are producing meat that way
other companies are ditching the initial
animal starter cells all together and
they can produce some meats excuse me
not meats they can produce some products
like leather milk egg whites gelatin
that don't use any animal starter cells
at all so for example there's a company
called gel Tour which is producing
gelatin and collagen that they are
already are selling on the market
they've already commercialized their
product so the first of these cellular
agriculture companies to commercialize
and they're not using any initial animal
starter cells at all how do you create
this leather without an animal starter
so oh it's pretty cool so in the same
way that you can have let's say Brewers
East and you feed it sugar and it
produces alcohol or you can a bake
resist and you feed it sugar and it
produces co2 to web and bread they take
special designer yeast and feed it the
sugar and it produces the proteins that
you want so in the case of leather which
is primarily collagen a protein in your
skin it produces that actual cattle
collagen and you can produce real
weather without any cow you have held it
in my hand many times in fact you can do
the same thing milk cows milk is about
half a dozen key proteins casein and
whey and so on and you can coax yeast to
produce those milk proteins and you add
water and some minerals and sugar to it
and it is the same as cow's milk without
any milk at all that's insane
yeah without the other hormonal
component that's right that's right and
you can you can tinker with this so you
can have no cholesterol you can make it
lactose free you are in complete control
because you're building it from the
molecule up really interestingly the
people who hear this like oh man that's
like so science fiction in reality every
bite of hard cheese that people are
taking in America today is made through
the same process because cheese has
rennet in it rennet is an enzyme that
used to come from calves intestinal
lining and it makes milk curdle into
cheese and now they don't really use
calf intestines and cheese anymore what
they do is they have done with the same
exact process getting a little
organisms to produce chymosin which is
the enzyme and rennet that's
functionally active and they produce it
through what's called synthetic biology
which is the same process that we're
talking about here and then they add
that synthetically produced chymosin
to the cheese and you get actual hard
cheese same exact thing except now
making milk or egg whites or leather or
gelatin and so on that is bananas yeah
yeah so like it's just it's crazy it's
crazy the acceleration with which we're
seeing changes like this in the world
from self-driving cars and Elon Musk
unveiling you know the semi yeah yeah
super car and like and the idea you know
that we're slowly acclimating to this
idea that that driving her own car is
gonna be an antiquated totally okay
vehicle actually drove a car like that's
but that's weird
and very dangerous yeah and and now
we're just being introduced to this idea
of clean meat and there is of course you
know some you know the hairs on the back
of your neck kind of go up and go well
that's weird and and and perhaps that's
a key we have this acclimation period
that I think we're gonna undergo that
we're gonna go through when we're trying
to kind of become socialized to this
idea for lack of a better phrase but I
don't see any way around it becoming the
thing that we're all going to be doing
like I you know and it's gonna take and
your book did a good job of like sort of
you know taking us through the history
of this and being very kind of
conservative about the timeframe here
like we're not writing it tomorrow
like most likely these products aren't
even gonna be on the market until at the
earliest like 2020 yeah they'll be on
the market in some limited senses I
think before then but in order for like
really commercially available in the
same way that you can go to the
supermarket and buy Guardian or
something like that yeah you're talking
a few years out but yeah I tried to be
conservative in the book about looking
at the potential I'm enthusiastic about
what these companies are doing but I
think we also should be cautiously and
cautious in that optimism but let me
just have a quick story because I think
people
have that sense like how this seems
unnatural and then future generations
may think how I was so unnatural the way
you did it before think about this so in
the wait Erik's like in the mid 19th
century everybody who is using ice was
using natural ice big natural ice
industry industry was formed around
harvesting ice from lakes and northern
latitudes and shipping that ice around
the world for people or have well enter
the advent of Industrial Revolution and
all of a sudden you have refrigeration
and now you have a way to produce ice
much more efficiently just by cooling
the water right in front of you down to
make ice well the natural ice industry
was livid over this advancement in
technology and they railed against it
calling it artificial ice saying it was
dangerous it was unnatural you had no
idea if it could sicken you because
nobody had been doing it for so long
they worried that the ammonia and the
coolant might leak out and poison you
when in reality the natural ice was
actually far less safe
you had contaminants from the industrial
revolution in the wakes the horses who
were being used to draw out the ice
we're of course going to the bathroom in
the wake while they're dragging it out
whereas so-called artificial ice was
being produced from water that had been
boiled or otherwise filtered before they
had cooled it down so the artificial ice
was way safer and now you fast forward
more than a century to today and every
single one of us has an artificial ice
maker in our homes we've called them
freezers and we don't think there's
anything unnatural about it at all is it
possible that clean meat will have the
same thing that we're gonna think now oh
that's unnatural
to have meat without animals to divorce
meat production from livestock raising
whereas in the future maybe they're
gonna think about slaughtering animals
for food as some type of a relic of a
primitive society I mean we used to have
all of our homes lit by whale oil and
kerosene came along and decimated the
whaling industry
what if clean meat makes a factory farm
seem as antiquated as a whaling ship
yeah you did that TED talk one of your
200 TED Talks that you've given where
you actually brought the harpoon under
the stage to demonstrate this point
that's very nice of you I don't
recommend trying to fly on an airplane
with a harpoon I
of having to just ship it via UPS it was
like a real six foot long harp no it was
like a legit yeah yeah this is not like
a decoration for your basement wall this
was like a vintage real harp and I put
right in this purpose well on a very
academic practical kind of you know
intellectual plane when you break it
down it doesn't make sense how we are
producing it we're so acclimated to it
this is the way we do it's the only way
we've ever known how to do it but when
you really evaluate the inputs required
to you know create that hamburger patty
or that chicken breast it's insane like
if an alien came down to the planet and
said like how are you creating food for
everybody and looked at you know how
much how many resources have to go into
creating these products this is
unsustainable right you can't keep doing
this they would think we were insane and
interestingly about aliens the very
first research ever funded into Queen
meat was actually funded by NASA because
they recognized that if we are ever to
leave our planet and start doing
long-distance cosmic tourism you for
astronauts they're not gonna be carrying
Noah's Ark until I mean if they want
meat they're gonna have to grow it and
in fact that's what they did on Star
Trek all right yeah I mean Queen meat
has been the purview of science fiction
for a long time including Star Trek and
NASA at the turn of the century thought
well what's fun to this and I funded
these researchers in New York to grow
real fish flesh outside of a fish and
they succeeded in doing it and these
dudes fried it up they couldn't get
permission from the FDA to eat it but
they fried it up they said it smelled
just like fish and then they they
unfortunately threw the meat they had
grown out but that was the first
breakthrough that cause it was in 2002
in this paper was published that showed
that this is actually possible and there
are some people like Jason Matheny who
was an early pioneer in the clean meat
movement who when he read that study
back in Oh to thought to himself why
would we do this in space we need to do
this here on earth right this is a
technology that could save us from
ourselves here on earth rather than just
thinking about how to feed astronauts in
space meanwhile were able to cultivate
human tissue in petri dishes right yeah
for burn victims and things like that so
it's
we're doing it on ourselves oh yeah
there are companies now if you get a
burn they can take a sample like a
biopsy from your skin somewhere else on
your body and grow not just human flesh
but grow a human skin that is your skin
like literally your skin and they put it
in the wound and your body accepts that
thinking that it's the natural skin
because it is your actual skin right
it's amazing it's really cool when you
think about that so you can do it for
medical purposes certainly certainly we
can do it for our fashion purposes too
not the human skin I'm not saying I
really need a human skin kit but you can
easily make leather coats and so on out
of these types of technologies well the
fashion implications the implications on
consumer products and garments that was
a super fascinating aspect of your book
and something I knew much less about it
didn't come up in my conversation with
Bruce and your thesis supported by you
know speaking with all of these you know
entrepreneurs in the space is that
that's gonna really be the first mover
yeah it's gonna be a lot no leather
products and you know perhaps egg whites
and things like that to follow but food
isn't really the tip of the spear
the harpoon hahaha it's possible so
there's this race of who's gonna be
first but yeah modern meadow is a
company that's really pioneering the
weather space in terms of cellular
agriculture and the CEO andris for GOx
has a theory that he thinks that it's
easier to get people to wear novel
materials than to eat novel foods that's
a very smart correct point right so
think about things like you know carbon
fiber gore-tex like those are people
didn't have any concerns about wearing
these brand-new novel materials that are
the product of new technologies we
welcome them we love them lightweight
things that keep us really warm and wick
away our sweat I mean that's awesome and
so if you can get people accustomed to
the idea of wearing leather that was
grown without the cow might it ease them
into the idea of eating meat that was
grown without a cow awesome and is that
on the same sort of time horizon 2020 is
that further out or is that where are we
in terms of being able to create you
know products for the marketplace it's
probably sooner so you might have mass
production by then but you'll probably
have some products on the market and a
high
and fashion type of way before them
mm-hmm yeah I think that it's much
needed yeah sort of my experience with
the faux leather like trying to sort of
you know be ethical in my purchasing and
sort of disappointed and what's
available there especially with like
shoes and things like that it's like
it's just not it's not there yet yeah I
mean the secret is like vegans delude
ourselves into thinking that these
products are all exactly identical we
think the the vegan meats tastes exactly
like meat we think the weather is
indistinguishable and I mean I like I'm
I use them I'm a fan but often times
people aren't fooled and being able to
have the actual so-called real thing
while divorcing it from the problems of
factory farming an animal agribusiness
in general I think is gonna be a major
breakthrough that is gonna lead to real
gains for animals in the planet yeah I
think what's a differentiating thing
here is is is the true sustainability I
mean the footprint of these products is
so low compared to not just animal-based
products but even synthetic products
like okay faux leather like okay you're
vegan so you're gonna buy your faux
leather shoes or whatever but let's take
a look at how that was produced and what
is the you know environmental impact of
creating that what were the dyes that
were used and you know and her was it
created and almost toys from
petrochemicals yeah right so there's
there's a lot of damage just because it
perhaps didn't involve an animal doesn't
mean that it's it's you know free of
impact yeah I often wonder about the
term cruelty-free because we tend to
mean it as a synonym to animal free but
it's pretty clear that there are lots of
ways to promote cruelty even when you're
not using animal being artificial dyes
into some water way and it's killing a
bunch of fish you can probably still
label that product as cruelty-free when
in fact it truly is
they were my very first job I worked on
this organic family farm back in
Maryland and I
and I was so psyched I was like in a
really romantic image of what it was
gonna be like to work on this bucolic
farm and one of the tasks they gave me
was to fertilize all of these plants
with fish blood and so I'm like walking
around and these are you know just for
vegetables you know you think what what
could be non-vegan about vegetables and
it was just a good reminder to me that
you know life is not black-and-white
that we find shades of gray and so many
things that we do and we shouldn't
pretend that there is some notion of
personal purity that we're going to
achieve because we're not I think the
name of the game is to try to do as much
good as we can to try to reduce the
amount of suffering that we're causing
and try to increase the amount of good
we're doing in the world but we
shouldn't delude ourselves into thinking
that we can be a hundred percent impact
free or cruelty free or whatever you
want to call it because all of us are
causing some harm and we should just try
to do enough good to outweigh that harm
as much as possible yeah it's a really
important point and and I think about
that a lot especially when I hear people
getting super righteous listen you know
we're all we're all we all have an
impact we're all creating some damage
you know as gene Baur would say it's
like it's an aspiration like you're the
best that you can but I think it is
important to telescope out and really
try to understand as best you can the
implications of all of these choices
that we make with respect to whatever
companies were patronizing and products
that were buying yeah for me it's
progress not perfection
I love genes line that being vegan is
more aspirational it's not all or
nothing it's just trying to aspire to do
the best that you can and I think
there's a tendency of some people to
become self-righteous over it but most
of us are living in glass houses and
it's not a good idea to start throwing
stones so this whole clean mean thing
was preconceived that's probably the
wrong word was was sort of
conceptualized by Winston Churchill
uh-huh yeah yeah it's the quote exactly
what he said
that was amazing yeah in 1931 Churchill
before becoming Prime Minister of the UK
wrote this essay fifty years hence it's
the name of the essay and he said that
we shall escape the absurdity of growing
an entire animal when you could simply
grow the parts that you just wanted to
eat and he was foreshadowing this idea
of growing meat without animals and he
was a few decades off admittedly but the
revolution that he foresaw is now in
full swing and you have these startups
like Memphis meats and Hampton Creek and
jail tour and perfect day and Clara
foods and so many others who are now
working to make real that vision and not
just an approve of concept type of way
which they've already done but actually
to start commercializing the companies I
just named have already raised millions
of dollars each with Memphis meats
Cargill the big agribusiness giant
invested in them showing that even the
meat industry thinks this is promising
and so I think for that reason you know
what Churchill envisioned might have
seemed very science fiction back then
but now it's pretty much science fact
the most science fiction thing that I
read in your book was this idea that one
day we wouldn't be purchasing these
products created by these clean meat
organizations but that we would actually
have our own like in-home rear whatever
it is like a toaster where we're
actually like in Star Trek where we're
able to just make it at home which is
like insane yeah I mean it's certainly
not possible today now you would need to
know what you're gonna eat many weeks in
advance but think about it look like
Moore's law you can see that happening
one would hope I mean we'll see I would
say this right now nobody thinks of it
as remarkable to have a bread maker in
their home or an ice-cream maker in
their home it's a cool gadget to have
maybe we will one day have meat makers
in our homes and you can order a little
tea bags of stem cells and you drop them
in and you can make your meat right
there I mean that's not in the
foreseeable future but it doesn't seem
that crazy that it would be completely
physically impossible to envision it
right that's so well on this subject of
you know talking about how active this
space is we have all these billionaires
that are investing everyone from Bill
Gates to Richard Branson and you know
Sergey Brin you know plays a large role
in the kind of early stages of
conceptualizing you know this industry
it's kind of painted in this silicon
valley picture sure because these are
these are tech companies that's right is
the latest in tech and that's very
exciting but another thing I was
interesting about your book is in
addition to the fact that perhaps
garments like leather goods are gonna be
the first mover in this space the United
States isn't necessarily the first
market or audience for these products
it's really China and Brazil and Mexico
right and it was the third one that you
mentioned yeah well nobody knows what
will happen but I do think that it's
very plausible that those countries that
you named and maybe India as well are
going to be some of the first early
adopters of these products because these
are our countries that have food
security concerns really rapidly growing
populations food safety concerns
especially in China and to the extent
that you have a technology that can
address all of those I suspect that it
would be welcomed and already a lot of
Chinese meat companies are talking about
this China just inked a deal with Israel
for 300 million dollars on clean tech
and the hope is that the Queen meat
companies in Israel and there are a
couple of them now already will be part
of that and get to hopefully sell clean
meat in China but other companies like
Hampton Creek certainly have their eyes
on on China li kai-shing who's the one
of the wealthiest billionaires in all of
Asia and a major investor in companies
like Hampton Creek and in others like
modern meadow though other producers
people like him certainly want to see
this in China and so I think it's
possible that's that is what happens
that those kind of those countries come
first and will do you what is the
regulatory landscape going to look like
like where where does it you know when
and where and how do the FDA and the
USDA begin to insert themselves into
this and try to exert a little control
over what's happening yeah well right
now these companies are meeting with the
agencies I mean as we speak these
companies are already in communication
with the agencies about this because
nobody really even knows who will
regulate them right now USDA regulates
meat production whereas FDA does fish
however the USDA's regulatory framework
assumes that there is going to be a USDA
inspector in a slaughter plant
monitoring the slaughter and seeing what
happens to the butchering process
needless to say none of that is relevant
and yeah that's very different from
walking into what is essentially a
biotech firm right right where there's
gonna be clean rooms and things that are
have nothing bears zero resemblance to
what they're sort of trained to
understand and regulate yes so that's
why a lot of people think it's gonna be
FDA and that's probably what will happen
I will say though right now it certainly
is produced in Queen rooms and people in
white lab coats but what will happen is
that when it's time to for
commercialization clean meat will be
produced in breweries and it's going to
look like a Sam Adams brewery not like a
factory excuse me not like a lab it'll
look more like a fact of food factory
than a lab and then what are these folks
do I guess they can ensure there's not
contamination in the actual brewery but
it's completely irrelevant to the
current system of meat inspection that
you have with USDA inspectors looking at
how animals are slaughtered and if their
intestines are being spilled out onto
the meat and so on getting over the kind
of quote-unquote ik factor for the
general public I would imagine is going
to be a hurdle and you know some
interesting stuff in your book about you
know how it's being presented and
marketed to the public and there's this
whole thing about like what are we
calling it you know cultured meat and it
was Bruce who came up with the phrase
clean meat right well because you did
all these studies like how does that
landed people and how you know how what
are people thinking about this how are
we going to get them to acclimate to
you know the idea of this as a palatable
alternative yeah thank good pun
palatable alternative so Bruce
popularized the term Queen Media did not
invent it but he did he did he did
popularize it with the good food
Institute and with good reason they did
consumer surveys and they found that
clean meat perform the best but as far
back as 2008 this dude a professor wrote
a letter to the editor to the New York
Times that they published in which he
bristled at a New York Times article
that had called this fake meat and he
said this is not fake meat any more than
how you know cloning a sheep would
create a fake sheep it's a real sheep
dolly was a real sheep and so he
suggested that because of the food
safety benefits if you want to call it
anything you should call it clean meat
and that idea really didn't go that far
until Bruce resurrected it and he's done
a very good job and admittedly I was a
little bit of a skeptic at first I was
one of the users of cultured meat and
Bruce persuaded me through the evidence
that he and GFI and eventually other
organizations and researchers found as
well that clean meat really is the best
in terms of named sequoya now admittedly
the best name to call it is just meat
because that's exactly what it is it
really doesn't need a specific
descriptor but in order to have a
conversation that is intelligible you
need to have some descriptor for it
right now at least maybe in the future
it will just be meat but for right now
we serve all the options that have been
pulled clean meat seems to do the best
my understanding is that we touched on
this a minute ago that it can be you
know pretty robustly manipulated in
terms of what you want it to you know
the the composition of these meats like
how many you know like what what is the
amount of saturated fat that we want to
have in here right we want it lean do we
want it more marbled do we want it this
and you can sort of dial these things up
and down as desired
yeah future of what this is look like so
you could specifically get exactly you
know the healthiest version or the
tastiest version yeah so there's a what
whatever divide in the clean meat
community over this so there are some
people who argue
to just be producing meat that is
identical to the meat that we have now
and have because that's what people want
that's what people are eating others
argue well it should be identical but
better now of course it's better for all
the reasons we've already noted but they
want it to for example have instead of
saturated fat you can imagine putting in
omega-3 fatty acids so you could have a
hamburger that instead of causing heart
attacks permits that's right no
saturated fat right now saturated fat
probably has a mouth feel that is
important for the burger that's why for
example the impossible burger has a lot
of saturated fat as one example but
we'll see what they do I think at first
we're probably going to be looking at
products that are nutritionally
equivalent to conventional meat but
safer from a food safety perspective but
in the future yeah I suspect that you
will have meats that are marketed as
healthier or have some type of some type
of claim that they're gonna be made of
foods that would be healthier than just
a regular slab of meat well certainly
healthier from the just from the gate
because it's not gonna have the
antibiotic right it's not gonna have you
know it's not gonna be have been
ingesting pesticides and GMOs rain and
all these other things that are you know
it's not gonna have bird flu things like
that you know that's one of the big one
of the big reasons I think to support
this is to reduce the limit of the
chance of a big flu pandemic a lot of us
don't think about it we're not that
concerned about things like bird flu
swine flu but keep in mind the Spanish
flu of 1918 which decimated tens of
millions of people at a time when there
were only a billion humans on the planet
with far less global travel that was
common that was from that type of a mix
from bird flu imagine if that happened
today where we have seven point four
billion of us on the planet with people
flying around the globe all the time you
could imagine it could be civilization
away threatening and in fact the
American Public Health Association even
editorialized on this issue saying that
the biggest way that we could reduce the
risk of such a pandemic again would be
to dramatically reduce the number of
animals who were raising for food they
envisioned it as a way for people to eat
less meat because the public
that several years ago that would
obviously be a great thing but with the
advent of clean meat
perhaps we can accomplish the same thing
without having to change so many
people's diets in the process most of us
have heard of Hampton Creek we know
about you know beyond meats we're
hearing more and more about impossible
burger and Memphis meats but who are the
other players who are the movers and
shakers in this space because it's not
just burgers and chicken breasts we're
talking about duck and foie gras and the
you know the leather products etc
there's a whole plethora of companies
and you kind of do these case histories
of how they came into being through out
the book super interesting thank you I
agree it is really interesting so a lot
of these people are just young idealists
who saw the problem a factory farming
and they wanted to address it in a way
that they thought would actually be
effective and efficient you know keep in
mind let's just back up and think about
even in the anti slavery days the
anti-slavery activists many of them if
not most of them we're still purchasing
slave produced cotton sugar and tea even
though they were for the abolition of
slavery they still felt like they for
whatever reason had a hard time buying
freely produced products in California
ten years ago we passed Proposition 2 to
been battery cages two-thirds of
Californians voted to ban battery cages
yet at that time 90% of eggs were
battery eggs being sold in the state so
it's very it's very difficult for us
often to align our values with our
actions many times we act differently as
consumers as we would as citizens and so
there's a theory that if you are going
to address this problem what's the best
way to do it to try to persuade millions
of people to individually change their
diets voluntarily or to create a new
system that renders the old system
obsolete and that appeals to people on
the factors that they're actually making
their purchasing decisions our price
taste and convenience so these companies
like for example let's take Clara Foods
as one example
Arturo Elizondo is the CEO and he
founded the company as a guy straight
out of college in his early 20s and he
founded it with two other folks and they
basically realized that egg whites are
just a few key egg proteins and they
could in the same way where we were
talking about creating leather and milk
from this process of synthetic biology
that they could create those types of
egg white proteins and add water to it
and you basically have egg whites and
they had this idea and they went and
they pitched it to an accelerator called
Indy by Oh run by a great guy by the
name of Ryan Bethencourt and they talked
to Ryan and he was very interested in it
and he gave them some free lab space and
some startup money I don't think it was
much it was like fifty thousand dollars
which of course is a lot of money in the
real world but for starting a company
it's not that much money and they proved
that they could do it and now they've
attracted millions of dollars of
investment and they want to be producing
clean egg whites perhaps starting for
the egg protein market at first like for
protein bars and shakes and so on and
they haven't yet commercialized but they
hope to be commercialized in the near
future and these are just these people
again who are in their 20s who were
thinking to themselves how can I make a
positive impact on the world think about
how horrible the egg industry is to
chickens so often and for the
environment and so on and they have come
up with a promising solution that
doesn't rely on millions of individuals
to voluntarily change their diets
they've come up with a solution that if
they could succeed would solve the
problem without people having to make
consciously different decisions mm-hmm
yeah change the environment you know
yeah that's right I mean think about
like most people don't have any idea
what source of energy they use they
don't know if it comes from coal or gas
or wind or solar but if you create a
situation where your energy for
renewables costs less than energy from
fossil fuels lots of people or the
company the power companies themselves
will just switch to that and people will
just go for that option it's not that
different than the idea that if you grew
up in Amsterdam you're probably gonna
ride your bike around all over
yeah what'd they do there you know what
I mean as opposed to living out here in
the middle of the country where that
would be not feasible like you know just
updating the environment and you know
the yes a good point the idea that this
is supplanting outdated tech you know
back to the harpoon example that we're
gonna look back on this and and consider
past practices as as barbaric but we're
in the you know we're in the midst of
this shift and with that comes
resistance because there's always
resistance right and the idea that this
is going to be literally replacing
something that is part and parcel of our
history like farming is America the
heart and like what does that say about
who we are as a country and this kind of
you know pastoral perspective we have on
that occupation and and all the people
that are involved in that yeah I think
that we've had a situation in the
country where the number of people
involved in farming has declined
basically every year for the most part
because it's just consolidating and
consolidating yeah a food production has
gotten a lot more efficient you need far
fewer people to grow the food that's
just the reality of it and clean meat
will make it even more efficient you
still have to farm I mean you still need
farmed ingredients to feed the cells but
you need fewer so one of the big
benefits is that it's less reason what
are you feeding them well right now it
is like a cocktail of various
plant-based ingredients and sometimes
even animal-based ingredients that would
never be used in the commercial sense
because both for ethical and financial
reasons it's just really expensive but
we've been culturing cells for over a
century and a lot of the time they're
cultured with animal ingredients so many
of the companies have already moved
beyond that in fact the companies are
doing egg whites and milk and leather
and gelatin aren't doing that at all but
the other companies are basically trying
to find plant-based ingredients that are
really cheap that will help the cells
grow and that's the real race is to
figure out what are the best plant-based
nutrients for these cells that causes
them to grow quickly mm-hmm and
cheap way right so there will be farming
for that tenant and perhaps the farming
that exists can go towards feeding
humans as opposed to feeding livestock
yeah and a lot of the land will
hopefully be rewired so you could have a
return to forests or to wetlands or
other types of conservation purposes
that you can capture carbon from the
atmosphere in the way that these lands
did prior to deforestation on that note
right now there's an interesting
movement afoot I think it's called the
ethical omnivore movement and perhaps
it's an outgrowth of the paleo movement
but the idea behind it as I understand
it and you probably know more is that as
opposed to kind of the the cowspiracy
what the health approach of look we need
to we need to just transcend animal
agriculture because it's destroying the
planet
it's this argument that actually the way
forward is to conceptualize new ways of
raising animals for food in a way that
is actually improving the planet yeah I
don't know if I got that right but maybe
you can speak to this a little bit
because there's a lot of people who are
interested in this as a counterpoint to
Cal Spira see for example what is the
what is your sense of the truth behind
this well just let's just keep it real
more than probably about 99% of farm
animals in our country are don't go
outside I mean they're in factory farms
I don't see the suddenly and I'll step
foot on a blade of grass the first time
they smell fresh air is when their back
of a truck just water and clean meat is
the antidote to that type of meat to the
extent that we give farm animals better
lives and let them live outdoors and a
type of what you're referring to as
regenerative agriculture I think it's a
big step in the right direction I would
welcome animals being treated better no
doubt about it I don't think that that's
a competitor of clean meat and I just
think that there are certain limitations
to that just scaling it up you're not
going to have nine billion animals
walking around on pasture you just don't
have enough land right Mike yeah my big
question is like if we do hit 10 billion
people or at 7.5 wherever we are right
now is it is it even a possibility that
you can achieve that yeah I don't think
that you can scale it up to the point
where you could have current levels of
meat consumption being adopted and the
proponents of regenerative agriculture
usually would say yeah we ought to eat
less meat which is great however my own
experience is that many of the people
who like this idea in theory are still
just eating meat you know just a
conventional meat and so do they say
that somebody is only eating that type
of meat of course I think that's a
better option than what most people do
but I don't think that it enables the
trends that we see continuing in China
India Brazil and so on where meat
consumption is skyrocketing
I don't think that you satiate that
demand for meat without factory farms or
with something like plant-based meats or
clean meats or some combination thereof
what about the ethical conundrum or
perhaps it's more accurately described
as a thought experiment the idea that as
things currently stand we have all of
these billions of animals walking around
if we fast forward to a time where clean
meat is what everybody's doing and we've
reduced these animals have we deprived
these animals the right to a life it's a
serious argument I mean there's an
interesting question I don't know
there's an answer to it but it's
interesting to kind of think about that
like okay as bad as the system is right
now we're providing lives to these
animals if we create a system that's
more ethically balanced is it better to
have those animals have a life that then
gets ended as opposed to them not having
a life at all well I certainly would
prefer for them to have lives that are
not miserable which is what they have
for this part now at the same time we
have to remember that these animals
don't live in a vacuum every
domesticated animal like a chicken or a
or a cow displaces wildlife feed is
raised is grown for them to feed them
that was once wild and and if you want
more wild free living animals and fewer
owned animals who were raising for food
then that's not necessarily the right
trade-off if however you want more farm
animals who have good lives and you want
them to displace wild animals then yeah
actually that would be your solution you
would want something like pasture based
systems where excuse me we're a farm
animals or outdoors and you don't have a
lot of life space around but you have
farmed animals there and you know just
depends on whether you want more wild
animals or you want more domesticated
animals right yeah that's interesting I
will say I'm not persuaded by the
argument that we're depriving anybody
from coming into existence I mean you
know think about it like this so you
have four kids presumably you could have
had a fifth like did you commit some
more I got none right you didn't mean
did you commit some more I really wanted
to be more sustainable right I would
have had no children well that's a
separate argument but let's just say
that you think that more is merrier
right so the argument that more farm
animals have good lives because your
kids I presume have great lives so you
know if you have a yeah we'll see what
they say about you when they're adults
but you know did you commit some moral
crime by not having a fifth kid I don't
think so you didn't deprive some you
know potential person No very few people
would make that argument that you're
somehow obligated to multiply as much as
you possibly can as a Peter Singer
spoken to this yeah I think what Peter
would say is that right now farm animals
don't have lives worth living that it
their life is a curse to them that bring
them into existence is just sentencing
them to misery but I don't think Peter
would have as much of a concern if they
had a very good life were killed
painlessly and had lives that were
overall better than the way that wild
animals would live because they are
displacing them but I don't want to
speak for him I'd want to ask him that
but my knowing Peter that's what I say
that's what I think he would say right
interesting so uma valetti was on the
cover it was it fortune or
Inc founder of Memphis meets a lot of
attention like this is part of the
public discourse now in a very large and
prominent way like this is happening
right it's amazing what asobi alive
yeah I mean it's I keep thinking like
well am I gonna be old enough to see
something you know like yeah I'll get to
see some of this stuff but like the the
lives that our kids are gonna be you
know that my kids are gonna be leading
like I just I can't even imagine it I
don't think that we can conceptualize it
we couldn't have conceptualized the
iPhone behind seeing Captain Kirk you
know using the using their version of it
when do you think do you really think
it's gonna be 2020 before we're gonna be
able to have a Memphis meat burger at
the grocery store that we can pick up
yeah I doubt that it'll be that soon
where you're just gonna have like
burgers on the shelves because they
won't be cost-competitive by them most
likely right but I do think that we're
talking about years not decades and it
just as a matter of how much money will
go into the Rd the biggest hope is that
the meat industry will get involved
Cargill's investment in Memphis meats
yeah that's really what sign the fact
that these big food companies are there
they know this is the future that's
right rather than be like the music
industry and cast a blind eye to what's
coming they're there they're investing
and they're getting involved now
yeah good analogy is the music industry
or even the film industry you know look
at the difference in the way that Canon
and Kodak responded to the digital
revolution they're both big gelatin film
manufacturers and Canon adopted it and
Kodak didn't and Kodak went bankrupt and
now Canon is the biggest digital camera
maker on earth and I think that there
will be meat companies that recognize
clean and plant-based meats as the
future and they will invest in them and
they will slowly become non animal meat
and other animal products purveyors
whereas others will stick to the old
antiquated model and they will suffer
the consequences and they will go the
way of a whaling ship or of gelatin film
I mean I remember when I was in high
school and in college you know you would
take your film to like CVS and
drop it off and come back later to get a
fotomat hots yeah right yeah you come
back later to get your your your prints
and hope that they came out well I mean
it's so archaic to think about and when
we when one-hour photo became available
we thought it was amazing like one hour
oh my god and now I mean imagine if you
had to wait one minute I mean you would
be outraged right yeah there's like
you'd be throwing your iphone into the
toilet right exactly if it was making
you wait that long yeah it's it's crazy
how that how that is and how we so
quickly acclimate to that you know like
I don't think our DNA or our genetic
wiring is really suited for the rapidity
with which were undergoing these kinds
of changes which is a whole different
podcast but and one with NFL with which
I totally agree yeah so what are the
current biggest barriers that these
industries are facing whether its
technological or or legal regulatory
yeah they don't face too many regulatory
problems yet because they're just not
getting ready to commercialize yet the
biggest barrier is bringing the cost
down they already know how to make these
products they just have to make them
much cheaper so the first burger that
was produced in 2013 which haven't had
the funding from Sergey Brin the
co-founder of Google that costs three
hundred and thirty thousand dollars
right I mean maybe the most expensive
burger ever consumed you fast forward
just four years and boom of a lady's
meatball was a comparative bargain of
$1200 now that's still a very expensive
dish to have you know spaghetti with
meatballs where it's $1,200 per feed
fall but it's a huge drop in the cost
and to use your iPhone example I mean
the first iPhone cost billions of
dollars to produce and now we're all
walking around with one in our pocket in
fact I read recently that if 10 years
ago you had wanted the photo editing
functions that Instagram has it would
cost over two million dollars now it's
just a free download
so everybody who is involved in these
companies believes they will bring the
cost down they just don't know how
they're gonna do it yet but they need
more money for R&D and to figure that
out
these companies are attracting millions
or in the case of some tens of millions
of dollars but they need more than that
I mean we need a type of like a
Manhattan Project to figure out how to
quickly scale these up and there are
some companies that are really serious
about doing just that well there is a
there is a bit of a Manhattan Project
right there's a whole chapter in your
book called Project Jake is all about
this not really a pivot but a redirect
of focus that the guys at Hampton Creek
are undergoing right now yeah so Hampton
Creek for a long time was just known as
a plant-based food technology company
and now they have a queen meat division
called Project Jake named after Jake the
sadly late dog but Josh Tetrick the CEO
and co-founder of Hampton Creek really
envisions clean meat as a major part of
the company's future not just a
plant-based food maker with a queen meat
division but really a queen meat company
that's a huge change from even just a
couple years ago definitely definitely I
mean they became famous for making
plant-based mayo and salad dressing and
now being Unilever lawsuit yeah yeah
ASCO well there's been a lot of like
interesting changes over there wasn't
there some big board shake-up and Josh
got rid of everyone I mean you probably
know more about that than I do I
remember reading something about some
significant executive shuffle happening
there they did have such a shuffle and
the company seems to be doing pretty
well now they just released their new
just scramble which I actually ate in
San Francisco yesterday at a restaurant
it was really excellent taste just like
scrambled eggs and they have new board
members and new executives and I think
the company is on the right track but
they have had some some bad media
attention that has shined a light in a
way on them that most companies I don't
think generally are treated with I think
a lot of companies that aren't so in the
spotlight just they don't they're not
subjected to that type of media scrutiny
because Hampton Creek has been so
successful I mean it was founded in 2011
and it already has evaluation today of
over a billion dollars and because
people like Josh Tetrick are so
high-profile there has been more media
scrutiny on them on then on other
startups which maybe have similar
problems in the startup life but just
escaped media scrutiny
so they're they're making this huge push
huge investment into clean meat yeah so
Josh Hetrick basically decided that you
look at the Unilever lawsuit and it was
all over whether you can call this
product mayonnaise or not the Conant
just may oh and you know whether you can
call it mayonnaise and if you can't call
it even Mayo it's very difficult if you
have to do what you know we've all read
one it was for them to call it like a
spread or a dressing you know that's not
what people were buying their buying
Mayo and the same is so there are
standards of identity for these other
products like chickens so if you look at
what all of the plant-based meat
purveyors making chicken call it it's
never chicken it's like some weird a
bastardization of the word yeah it's
like chick ' and there's like chicken
with an eye instead of an e there's
always something like chicken free
chicken all these words that they have
to use because they're not legally
allowed to call it chicken and that
creates a barrier in the mind this is
the same reason why the dairy industry
doesn't want the plant-based milk
companies are called milk because the
same thing with cheese that's exactly
right
if you make cheese from nuts like
Julie's cookbook they don't want you to
call that cheese they want to call it a
nut spread anything of something more
repulsive than not spread so the dairy
industry well nut cheese yeah they need
better marketing in that field yeah but
with Queen meat the hope is that you
will be able just to call it what it is
me right but differentiate that's
exactly right it is real actual meat and
that's what Josh's theory is that
plant-based chicken could do a lot it
could take over a large portion of the
market hopefully right now it's a
minuscule portion but hopefully it could
go to a large portion but unless you can
actually call it chicken there does seem
to be some type of a natural limitation
as to how much consumer acceptance you
have the other interesting thing about
Hampton Creek and this is in your book
is is akin to the way that Elon Musk has
sort of approached his technological
breakthroughs with batteries in the
sense that he's making this information
available Hampton Creek is saying look
we're gonna crack the code on this clean
meat stuff and then we'll just license
you how to do it like we want everyone
to do it rather than protecting that IP
and locking it down and trying to
control the market yeah that's exactly
right Josh Tetrick has zero interest in
being the only clean meat purveyor he
wants to help really solve this problem
of factory farming and so their goal is
to become a licensure of clean meat
technology as two big meat companies
rather than just being a queenly
producer themselves and I think that
goal is shared by a lot of other people
in this space too because nearly
everybody who's involved as an
entrepreneur in this sure they want to
make money but their goal is to solve a
problem it's to get into the game and
provide an alternative that renders the
current system of animal agriculture
obsolete so that we can move beyond
these problems that are plaguing
humanity and the planet I mean right now
we're sitting just miles away from
raging wildfires that are almost
certainly if not caused by exacerbated
by climate change and we all know these
listeners of this podcast probably know
animal agriculture is a leading cause of
climate change a leading cause of
greenhouse gas emissions and at what
point do we say we need an alternative
we cannot just rely on people just to do
the right thing because it's the right
thing I wish that we did that but sadly
were humans and humans are very fallible
certainly myself included and if we
don't have an alternative that is
convenient that is better than the
current system that is cost competitive
with it
I don't see how we win yeah all the
greenhouse gas emissions just so we're
super clear it's something like 15
percent attributable to animal
agriculture more than the transportation
sector combined and you do a great job
in the book of kind of canvassing all of
the environmental implications and all
of the resources that need to be
Marshall to create these animal products
especially water right I can what is it
with you even broke it down by egg
whites I think how much water is
required to just create an egg yeah well
first dude I'm honor that you read the
book so closely I can tell from the
interview that you really read it you
know sometimes you do interviewing
people they really
I haven't so my hat is off to you I'm
grateful but second yeah I mean it takes
about 50 gallons of order to produce one
egg this one egg 50 gallons of water
think about that I mean think about if
you were for example to every time that
you ate one egg you had to open up 51
gallon jugs of water and dump them out
on the ground first
nobody would ever do that yeah yeah that
is what that is what it takes and it's
important to you but not like Bruce has
this example that you have in the book -
like if you're gonna eat up a plate of
pasta you know throw out nine plates and
pasta you know net that kind of is a you
know a demonstrative way of showing you
how much how much has to go into these
products to create them and how much
waste and byproducts there are yeah huge
amounts I mean water is just one of the
inputs but feed land oil I mean though
it goes on and on and on it's such an
inefficient way to produce protein for
us and we need a better alternative so
are you gonna be a consumer of these
products I don't know I mean I don't
have a great desire myself to eat it
honestly I ate it for the book I think
and I kind of thought it was cool too I
think I thought like it would be an
interesting story but I don't you
couldn't write the book without trying
it yeah I agree I totally agree with you
but I don't have a big desire to eat
meat so I I do like plant-based meat so
I don't eat them that often and I like
eating them if somebody offers me
something I eat it it's a holiday but I
don't like go to the supermarket and
just buy them on a regular basis because
I just don't have a big desire to eat
meat yeah I'm with you like it it's I'll
have a pion burger every once in a while
like if we're at veggie grill or
something like that with the kids but
I'm like past it like I'm not the
consumer I'm not the market yeah for
this product I've recognized that
there's a massive market and a massive
need for this I'm just not gonna be the
person who's gonna be lining up to eat
it yeah well interestingly enough the
consumer surveys show that there is a
inverse relationship between how much
meat you eat now and whether you're
interested in eating Queen me so the
West meat you eat now the West's
interest you have an eating clean me the
more meat you eat now the more interest
you have and so is that about oh it just
shows vegetarians don't want to eat meat
I mean it's not not that radical of a
notion but I mean I find that even
vegetarians tend to be really thrilled
about products like beyond meat and so
on I mean I I was at the giving a talk
at the Kansas City veg fest recently and
you know there's a vegetarian festival
and the longest line was for the beyond
burgers you know like even coming there
people aren't getting quinoa and lentils
there they're getting beyond burgers but
for the most part I think vegetarians
are not that thrilled about the idea of
eating actual animal meat and so they're
not the target you and I are not the
target for the clean meat companies the
shoppers who are buying conventional
meat from fast-food companies and from
big-box grocers those are the target
yeah I actually have tried the
impossible burger now three times
uh-huh and all three times I was like
this is not for me freaked me out like I
didn't like it there just it just it was
weird yeah and and God bless them like
I'm glad that company exists in their
doors in the world and I'm you know I'm
hopeful and that you know a lot of
people will discover and love their
products and and switch accordingly but
like yeah I was like now yeah I think I
like the idea of being able to walk into
a restaurant and order a burger as if I
were like a normal person
we'll find a social perspective that's
yeah like when Ben and Jerry's came out
with vegan ice cream there's plenty of
vegan ice creams on the market but the
idea of being able to just go to Safeway
and buy Ben and Jerry's it was a very
attractive idea to me because I could
feel like I was just like a normal
person rather than this vegan who
doesn't eat you know most of the things
that you find written in there so I like
it for that reason for myself but I
really care if I never ate it again
honestly right so what's the the biggest
takeaway that you want people to have
from this book this is a nascent
industry this field of cellular
agriculture that has the potential to
address many of the most pressing
sustainability problems that we face as
a species we ought to welcome it with
open arms we ought to encourage it we
ought to tout it and we ought to
encourage those who have the capital to
invest in it to help bring it to
commercial reality it's still too early
to predict what's going to happen with
the clean meat industry but it's one of
the most
hopeful solutions we have to one of the
worst problems that we are enduring and
so my hope is that anyone who is
concerned about addressing climate
change or animal cruelty or
environmental degradation or food safety
problems will look at this with an open
mind and think this is a cool promising
solution that deserves my support beyond
your book where are the other places
people can go to learn more about clean
meat and these issues so clean meat calm
is the website with lots of information
about it where you can not only see more
about the book but you can also if
you're interested in working for one of
these companies they all have lots of
job openings right you put the job
posting yeah yeah all the companies on
your on that website dozens of job
openings right now in this field you can
learn a lot more also at clean meat org
which is the good food Institute's
website about clean meat so there's
queen meat calm and clean meat org both
of which are great websites and I would
encourage folks to not only read the
book of course buy copies for all your
friends and your family but to when
you're engaging with people on social
media cuz it's gonna be a lot more news
attention on this as these companies get
closer and closer to commercialization
to get active in the conversation a lot
of people have what you were calling the
ick factor and they think just
instinctually oh that's gross but when
they start considering just how
unnatural current meat production is all
of a sudden clean meats and took a much
naturally preferable option and when we
talk about it in those type of terms I
think it opens people's eyes and their
hearts up to these products in a way
that it doesn't otherwise yeah I think
education will solve that I mean I think
that the biggest thing is you know we're
kind of in the in the midst of this
debate or discourse around the
implications of GMOs in our plant foods
right that kind of what doesn't get
discussed is the fact that we're eating
meat that hasn't been eating all of
those GMOs but at the same time like
that's an important conversation to have
and I don't know that we really have the
answers that that we need at this point
so like I said earlier I think it is
good to be asking these questions about
the implications of these new products
on human health but from what I
understand reading your book and the
more research that I do into this I'm
more and more comfortable with the idea
of it that's cool and I think that if
you look at GMOs they were introduced
into the market in a quiet way where
they just took over the food supply and
people didn't really think nobody goes
out and buys GMO corn they just buy corn
because it became all of the corn
basically and the reality is that the
companies involved in the clean meat
world don't want that they don't want to
go stealth under the radar they are into
radical transparency they want people to
know how they are producing their foods
they're putting videos of their
production processes up they want to
have public tours of their facilities
the taking they're basically taking the
exact opposite tactics as the GMO
purveyors did when they started
introducing these products a couple
decades ago and I think that type of
radical transparency will go a long way
and showing that there's nothing to hide
I mean if anything what's to hide is the
current way of producing me not the new
way yeah and I think that Millennials
and the generation Beneatha these these
are people that demand that kind of
transparency yeah they expect it you
know and the idea that a company is not
going to be telling you exactly how
things are being done it just doesn't
work anymore you know and so I think
that's really cool that that is that
sort of industry-wide all of these
companies agree that that's the path
forward
yeah unanimous agreement yeah that's
cool yeah all right man well we got to
lock this down but the book is clean
meat and it doesn't look like this
binder clip cover on it it's available
at bookstores everywhere and it's a it's
a gift to humanity man I really enjoyed
reading it and I think it does a
fantastic job of explaining exactly
what's going on in a way where people
can really not only understand all the
sort of intricacies and aspects of of
what this is about like you track the
history of how it came into being and we
get to learn these personalities behind
these companies and these scientists
and you know I think it's going to
really serve people in this acclimation
process which is cool I appreciate a man
it's real honor to be on the show with
you as you know but I want to declare to
all listeners when I read finding ultra
I had never thought of myself as being
capable of doing something like a
marathon and I always thought that was
for other people and when I read it I I
declared to my friends and my family
after reading and I was like you know if
rich role could do this at age 40 you
know I was in my 30s I can run a
marathon
- now I wasn't doing Ironman or anything
like that but I thought that was it for
me it felt like the equivalent thereof
and I went out and and did run the
Marine Corps Marathon and it was the the
causal relationship was very direct from
reading finding ultra to that so I'm
grateful for you know thanks man well
you did the work but that's very cool to
hear I had the good fortune of meeting
your parents - yeah proud of you first
met in Washington at the DC VegFest a
couple years ago yeah they were psyched
to meet you especially my father you're
a big celebrity to him and he was he was
adamant about making sure that you knew
that he ran the Marine Corps Marathon in
1983 faster than I realized in 2013 made
that made that point abundantly clear
how is the running going are you still
running I'm running shorter distances
because I wanted to put on more muscle
mass so I did I looked good buff I
appreciate that man thank you
I did I did run a 5k recently I was
psyched that I was able to keep it under
seven minutes I've mentioned a 6:56
average pace so for me that was pretty
good good it's only for a 5k but I'll
take it
and what else is going on with you here
in California
well one my girlfriend Tony Okamoto
lives here so I'm very grateful to be
out here to be able to hang out with Tim
coming out here all the time I'm out
here quite often
yeah like call me next time all right
man she doesn't live in that way but I
would love you know why it's on my
bucket list to go running well yeah well
we can do it next time okay I'm in so
you know as I'm also though in addition
to having the personal interest of being
out here there's a ballot initiative
that
would improve conditions for farm
animals that keeps me out here pretty
frequently as well cool and are you
doing any like talks or their anyway if
people want to like come out and hear
you talk about this stuff or you have
any events coming up or anything like
that there are some book related events
that I'm doing and you they'll be on
clean meat calm and people can go check
that out and get the details on them
yeah and I'll put up in the show links
you know some of your your past
appearances oh cool thank you and
200,000 TED Talks so these are these are
TEDx talks I did four of them in a
period of two months which really
dramatically reduced the welfare of my
close circle it I only could find I
found Sun Valley and I found I found
South Lake Tahoe yes so they're not
online yet because they were all recent
and they are just two of them are just
getting online right now but I love
doing them and their own different
topics they're come up with like a new
time like rehearse it and get it done
and execute by by torturing my cos
friends by forcing them to listen to me
create these materials but you know one
of them is on the abuse of power that
humans have over other animals another
one is on clean meat another one is on
what future generations will think about
our Treatment of Animals and then the
final one which is I think one of the
most crazy ones is whether we're doing
more to protect aliens on other planets
than we are animals on our planet right
so you know you think about it like we
take great precautions to avoid
contaminating other celestial bodies we
bake our equipment and all types of
really serious expensive precautions
because we don't want to cause some type
of the extinction event on Mars or
elsewhere in the same way that for
example European colonists did in in the
Americas and we don't seem to be that
concerned about preventing extinctions
here on earth we don't even know that
these aliens exist up there they maybe
don't but we seem pretty concerned about
it so that's the fourth one maybe we
should start here here
yeah I mean I'm I'm all forward there
taking the precautions elsewhere I think
it's very noble I just would use that
mentality here on earth as well yeah
this idea that we're just well this is
disposable like we got to find a new
place now let's just like burn it down
yeah get to Mars as quickly as possible
that's that's you know yeah well there
is the question of you know is the solar
system better off with us on her side oh
no we haven't done that great of a job
right yeah our track record would
indicate that the earth would be much
better off without us
maybe the the biggest extinction event
of humankind might be in in the best
interest of the galaxy yeah I mean it's
hard to tell the the optimism of certain
people like Elon Musk is that yeah we
have a bad track record but if you look
at the future that maybe we're going to
be able to abolish suffering and be able
to create these intensely blissful
beings through AI and so on and so if
you accept those premises you can see
how you might be able to say oh all of
this past suffering we've caused has
been worth it because it sets up for
this great utopian heaven in the future
I don't know so much about that but
human nature is still but I appreciate
his optimism and things are getting
crazy that's for sure
yeah you better believe it so all right
cool man we got to jump here but people
can find you multiple places on the
internet clean meat calm clean meat org
at Paul H Shapiro on Twitter thank you
yeah web site is Paul Shapiro calm Paul
- appear calm but yeah just go to Queen
meet calm you'll get everything there
there you go
cool thanks reg thank you so much it's
awesome to talk with you you want to
take me yet you want to take us out you
know what I say at the end of these
things 1.5 speed I do listen at 1.5
speeds so doing the interview with you I
had to make sure I'm talking at one
point Oh speed because I listened to you
at 1.5 but there's always ads at the end
so I am not so inclined always to
whistle I always end it was saying peace
oh yes I do know that I don't say it
peace and plants and plants meet I guess
yeah peace plants and a future filled
with breweries of clean meat right
[Music]
you